well very good to talk to mr ambassador
just before we start on the substance of
the interview i want to put what we're
about to hear from you today into
context because you'll remember the last
time we spoke was on january the 11th at
the beginning of this year
in that interview i asked you what 150
000 russian troops were doing on the
border around ukraine did they have any
intention of invading to which you
replied to me
in the current and foreseeable future we
have no intention
to do that
to be blunt mr ambassador you were
deliberately misleading me
in fact that was a lie
you can consider it as what you said but
i have said what i didn't know at that
moment
and i can assure you that uh every
ambassadors all around the world russian
investors had only the same knowledge
about that
six weeks after that interview russian
forces invaded ukraine and you're
telling me that the kremlin's
representative in london a key
diplomatic posting is not aware
of its own foreign policy well it is not
for the first time i am being asked this
question of course not
this was a military operation and uh
well
in no country people has kind of
advertising in beforehand the military
operations like that
but the plans were clearly in place and
you were not told
well this is not a surprise to me
does this happen with many other areas
uh i can remember uh
things in the security council before a
major nuclear explosion where our
minister or was garminko at that time
very many years ago was not aware of
that either were you embarrassed then by
that by the fact that you had to go out
and it wasn't just me of course to the
british media you had to go out and lie
you were misled by the kremlin
now we have to avoid this kind of
wording
lies and don't lies there are a lot of
lies on behalf of your government about
the military operation because absence
total absence of knowledge about that
about what is happening in ukraine
because there is only a unilateral
supply of information
by for your government and for british
public british public is not aware of
that either
it's interesting though the parallels
with what's happening i want to get your
views on the the change of
administration
the resignation of boris johnson because
one of the main reasons that his party
has turned upon him because he sent
ministers out in public having misled
them and they felt that they were being
asked to lie on his behalf
that's
as it may be you must be glad
russia must be glad to see the back of
boris johnson because of his solid
support for president zielinski and
ukraine
uh i can see that boris johnson is
leaving as for us the worst possible
impression
in the sense that he stick to the policy
that russia should be defeated and
ukraine should will win this was totally
wrong this is miscalculation of
strategic miscalculation of what is
happening over there because potentials
of ukraine both in economics term and
military terms are incomparable russia
is winning and winning pretty quickly
terrain and so on uk is trying to supply
weapons to ukraine the longer it will
supply weapons to ukraine but the more
suffering of ukraine it will be and more
goals we are going to achieve but it's
very unlikely that whoever takes over
his british prime minister is going to
change that approach that putin must
fail there are those in the
administration now who say he is a war
criminal there are those that say that
russia must leave the entirety of
ukraine including crimea and that
there must be members of the russian
forces appearing before war crimes
tribunals
well first and foremost we have a record
of crimes that has been committed by
during eight years when ukrainians were
bombing their bus selling innocent
people over there killing peaceful
citizens and they continue to do the
same
now in the area of harkov in the south
of ukraine in denmark specifically it is
it continues for eight years we have
this record and we will apply to that
my russians are doing my second okay
let's accept the ukrainians are doing
that but russians are doing it don't
interrupt me
we have an agreement if you will
continue to interrupt me i will stop the
interview okay well i just wanted to
make the point that you're accepting
that war crimes are taking place they're
accusing the ukrainian side perhaps it
should be for a court to decide about
the ukrainians and the russians when it
comes to war crimes as i have said uh we
have a long record of ukrainian crimes
committed during after to adapt
over the year and during a civil war
which continued for eight years shelling
bombing killing civilian people innocent
people over there so this is one thing
so the other thing which you have asked
me is about so it is clear by now that
ukraine is losing grounds and we are
gaining grounds in donbass and uh
actually for me it is interesting what
will be the exit strategy of uk
government if it will if it will
continue to repeat that ukraine should
prevail
can i ask you that it is simply
unrealistic can i ask you then in terms
of the territorial games gains that
russia is making in the donbass
if it should catch the entirety of the
donbass is there likelihood of a
ceasefire is this the way russia sees it
this is the way the war could end
i do not know frankly speaking that all
depends on we have suggested many times
negotiations and ukraine can stop
the war
next day if it will cease
offences if it will cease
pull down weapons and say let's
negotiate in fact what do you want and
they know what we want actually
well just be explicit because so
therefore russia does no longer want the
fall of the zelensky regime russia no
longer desires to capture kiev in the
entirety of ukraine we never see we have
none of our leaders neither president
nor the others have seen that we would
like to turn over
the zelinski or his team we have
differences with them but they are
negotiatable
let me ask you about specific issues
around particularly right now and this
is affects the entirety of the world the
issue of ukrainian grain the un
estimates that 400 million people
globally depend upon
wheat and grain from ukraine to feed
them it's currently blockaded there are
talks we know making some progress can
you update us on the russian position
how likely is it that russia will allow
exports of ukrainian grain soon
the problem is extremely exaggerated
ukraine is producing about one percent
of the wheat or even the whole earth it
is exporting about eight percent of it
so we are exporting twice as much as
ukraine for instance so
we are not against we do not put
obstacles uh for ukraine to air for
exportation of grain from its port of
odessa and so yesterday in turkey uh
there was a meeting uh four part-time
meeting together with the united nations
as a lead uh next week it will be
another meeting to finalize an agreement
and we just demonstrate our good will so
the issue is now to demand the entry to
add their support and nikolai port the
mining can be done only by the
ukrainians because ukrainians have put
mines over there
and if ukrainian ships
maritimes
ships merchant ships
carrying grain want to have nato
escorts will russia allow that i don't
think so we cannot turn the black sea
into uh and allow nato ships over there
and neither turkey will allow this
because it is the
uh it is
under
which convention
sorry forget the name of the convention
now but it is uh under international law
the military ships cannot pass the uh
without permission of turkey over there
but if you're saying if ukraine demines
the area around the portables
their merchant ships are free to say
merchant ships will be escorted i do i
do think uh and this is now on the
negotiation table by probably but turks
will take part in it we are establishing
a control center in turkey right now
which will uh
follow this
gas um north stream one the pipeline to
germany is closed for maintenance at the
moment so there are fears in europe that
it actually won't reopen that this will
be russia exerting more pressure on the
european union
difficult to say uh what is happening is
a normal situation the technical
maintenance is also going on during this
time
during this time of the year but on the
other hand
one should understand that it is not us
but this is european union who said by
by the year 2030 they will totally
minimize
consumption of gas oil energy from
russia and by this year they will
terminate it so they are gradually
reducing consumption of our energy
sources and issues now uh of course we
would like to fulfill all our contracts
and to be to have a reputation we have a
reputation of reliable supplier and we
will continue to supply that but on the
other hand we should also take measures
to find some alternatives
because by this time when they are
reducing it
we need to find other markets for this
and please take into account that we
didn't start yet out of our counter
sanctioning we are sanctioned very of
quite a lot by the european union in
different fields we have our government
is of course preparing measures for
counter-sunshine
this is clear the trade volume between
european union and russia this year is
about 280 billion of dollars so we are
interrelated
but uh we may stick to this policy so of
course sooner or later we will have to
take measures
can i ask mr ambassador about the um
situation with the two britons and there
are others uh two britons who are
fighting uh amongst and with as members
of the ukrainian forces who are captured
by russian separatists in the donbass
and sentenced to death eden aslan and
sean pinner
is russia putting influence upon
those supporters of russia in the
donbass to at least commute those
sentences of course russia does not
carry out the death sentence
as to my knowledge they have put a
notice of appeal to the uh court in
donbass and it is under consideration uh
and depending on the issue uh the it
will be the result but so far uk
government did not address us and they
don't approach us with a demand or that
we can we should intervene
it will be of course a bit awkward to
think that
due to the position that uk government
is now taking adversarial position to us
that we deliberately will advocate
something on behalf of the uk government
in front of donbass and just to get back
to the uk government the change at the
top and
will presumably be a change in many of
the major positions as well what
attitude would russia like to see the uk
take towards it and the conflict in
ukraine
it should be first of all realistic
because the conflict will not continue
forever
the conflict will end
and
the conflict may end pretty soon
because if of course uk will understand
that there is no possibility to win over
russia but it will the conflict will be
prolongated if uk will continue to
supply arms which are now being used
also for selling
cities and civilian people
in
donbass and in the other areas
and the more uk will uh send weapons the
longer will be the conflict because they
are encouraging ukrainian soldiers and
ukrainian authorities not soldiers but
authorities to continue the conflict i
want to just ask you about those weapons
that are being supplied of course not
just by the united kingdom and we hear
from russia today there's been
another strike where russia claims that
12 people have been killed and that uh
the united states the united kingdom the
west are conducting hybrid warfare you
say that the war may soon end but it
could escalate then could it not if
russia decides that it wants to attack
for instance
where those weapons are being assembled
supplied where the training is taking
place it could
go beyond the borders of ukraine
on the territory of ukraine we are well
our militaries they are striking only uh
goals and the achieving goals only on
the territory of ukraine if it but if it
is foreign weapons being sent or
mercenaries are being trained on the
territory of ukraine only then of course
this is a legitimate military target for
us
and in terms i just want to talk about
escalation because it is a very hot war
in the heart of europe
russia has said in the past has
mentioned has informed the world about
the scale of its nuclear capability
president putin says that russia will
use such weapons to defend its
sovereignty to defend the sovereignty of
russian territory russian territory
does include crimea does it in russia's
estimation
uh we have a military doctrine and the
answer lays in this military experience
there are two options when we may use
the
nuclear weapons one is that we are being
attacked by the nuclear forces from
abroad and the other if conventional
attack is so heavy that it is endangers
our
existence of russia